will return back to 1770 and look at
what leonhart Euler said at the time
mathematicians have tried in vain to
discover some order in the sequence of
prime numbers but we have every reason
to believe that there are some mysteries
which the human mind will never
penetrate okay and 30 years later here's
a quote from Gauss the problem of
distinguishing prime numbers from
composite numbers and resolving
composite numbers into their prime
factors is known as one of the most
important and useful in arithmetic all
methods have been all methods that have
been proposed thus far are either
restricted to very special cases or are
so difficult that they try the patient
patience of even the practiced
calculator the dignity of science itself
seems to require that every possible
means be explored for the solution of a
problem so elegant and so celebrated wow
so these two great thinkers have really
set the stage for the challenge ahead of
us and now I'm going to fast forward to
2010 and show you a paper that came out
of the RSA competition which is a
competent competition that no longer
runs but the purpose of the competition
was to put out a large number and say
can anyone factor it so in 2010 this
winning team factored a 768 bit number
and that means it was a 232 digit number
if you're thinking in base 10 so this
team in 2010 they won the competition by
factoring a 232 digit numbers so that's
how far we have come from from you know
Euler to or we can go back to Euclid but
from Euler to 2010 we're at 232 digit
numbers and here was the answer in their
paper so this was the first prime this
was p 1 and this was p 2 so this is the
state of the art right now okay how did
they factor this number and what is the
state of the art techniques well we're
going to go back and build from the
beginning and this kind of defines
computational number fee
that is the topic of this adventure so
what a computational number theory mean
well computation comes from the greek
word for gravel stones were used for
counting computation is any type of
calculation whether you're using stones
or a ruler or a slide rule or a
calculator or this cool looking machine
which is babicz it Babbage's Difference
Engine which was a hand-powered
calculator it doesn't matter what you're
using or you're using a computer you're
doing some sort of computation and now
what kind of computation are we doing
number theory and that involves this
mysterious distribution of prime numbers
studying this distribution and what
we're actually looking at is
multiplicative number theory which is
questions of how do you factorize
numbers how do you tell me if a number
is prime and so forth and we begin with
a very simple question or not a question
a challenge we need to build a machine
which takes an input and that input is
some integer X and all that machine
needs to do is output true or false and
that is the first step now we will use
the computer science tool to actually
build this machine together and one of
the questions that will we will be
asking is two things two aspects to this
machine how much time that's a clock how
much time does it take to give the
solution and how much space does it need
and when I say space I mean for in the
case of this mechanical calculator
physical space how many rooms do we need
to hold our machine or if we're using a
computer how much memory does it need so
we will be returning to these two ideas
as we go